so I'm Kirsty Nathu I'm a partner at Y
Combinator and also the CFO and our next
speaker is Aileen Lee and alienness the
founder of cowboy ventures which has a
fund that invests in seed stage
companies before starting cowboy
Aileen was at Kleiner Perkins and she's
also spent time at Gap and Morgan's
family alien is also famous for coining
the term unicorn which you probably
stick to the hearing about now infamous
or famous yeah and we actually invite
aliens to talk to our founders that why
see every batch and the reason why is
that we just love that she gives this
amazing no-nonsense advice to our female
founders about about talking through
investors so I'm excited to be able to
chat with her today and in front of
everybody thank you okay so Aileen we've
I gave a little bit to be history there
but why do you go into a little bit more
detail and about how you what made you
decide to go off on your own and spout
cowboy so cowboy ventures is still kind
of a start-up we started five years ago
and I had been at Kleiner for a long
time actually almost 13 years and I part
of the time from oh seven 2:09 actually
kind of left part-time and went to go
run one of our portfolio companies and
CEO and when I came back I just had a
different feeling about the firm and the
work and I found that I was I was
fortunate to be a senior partner at
Kleiner at the time and as you for these
large firms you said just like large
companies as you kind of get into senior
management you spend more and more your
time in meetings less kind of doing the
functional work and more around kind of
trying to help run the firm of it and I
just really love working hands-on with
founders and with portfolio companies
and I just felt like our firm had kind
of grown quite large and spending more
time on internal meetings and actually
just spending time with companies and
the industry had changed a lot too I
mean as you all probably know there are
a lot more funds now
there are a lot more startups they can
be all around the country and so venture
investors really have to be kind of open
for business and available to meet with
companies all the time because you just
don't really you know you never really
know what's under the hood unless you
have a meeting and you meet people and
so I just I felt like having a job where
all I really did was just meet with
companies get to know challenge the
people who might start companies who
might want to work at portfolio
companies and helping portfolio
companies is really all I wanted to do
with less overhead and seed with this
new category that was still pretty small
in terms of the number of firms and also
the number of well-respected brands in
the seed category that we're known for
giving hands-on help and yet it was it's
the biggest it's kind of the the biggest
part of the funnel and so it seemed like
a great opportunity to both start
something new make it more personal make
it very small with very little overhead
we're really all we do is is very pure
and very focused and so what did you
what did you see at kleiner in places
like that but you decided you were going
to do differently with your fund
anything it did get quite large and I
think this isn't specific to kleiner but
in general the massive venture capital
is such that but venture capitalists
make money through a combination of fee
income and what is called carried
interest which is basically profit
sharing with their investors once you've
returned the capital and when you do the
math on funds if you have a 500 800
billion dollar 800 million or billion
dollar fund the number of multi-billion
dollar companies that you have to be an
investor in per fund is quite large it's
when you do the math it seems very
unlikely that most venture capital firms
will be able to generate the kinds of
returns to investors and to themselves
that they have in the past
and so the math I think just works much
better it's much more aligned with
entrepreneurs if the funds are smaller
that was one thing but I well I won't
mean having the chance to be a female
founder and hopefully build a brand that
gets very hopefully well respected by
entrepreneurs and investors for being a
blue-chip top tier firm in terms of the
quality of work the quality of
relationships the integrity and the
outcomes and helping to put numbers on
the board and move the needle for women
in tech is something that really
motivates me yeah yeah and you mentioned
that one of the things that you wanted
to have more of a hands-on approach with
helping the founders that you that you
invested in what kind of things do
founders ask you for help with and how
can you help them well at seed stage I
know it's hard to suppress to see but
how many of you out there are founders
oh wow that is awesome
so it's an how many of your seed stage
or precede founders okay a lot so it's
DJ jazz you know your you know you have
not enough time not enough money not
enough people and so founders generally
want advice or help or guidance on a
multi multiple fronts one is on hiring
many times the founder has never hired
certain types of people before they've
never hired a head of sales or they
never had hired a UX designer and things
like that so they like advice and both
introductions and help filtering and
knowing kind of where to set the bar in
terms of who to hire when and how to
know that the right people on the
financial plan as many of you may know
the bar has kind of been raised in terms
of how much series a of investors want
to see you accomplish from seed stage
before you raise an A and then from A to
B and B to C because a lot of these
funds have gotten bigger they have more
money they can kind of wait and write a
bigger check at a higher valuation for
more traction and so I think at seed or
even precede getting good advice from
experienced folks on what you really
need to prioritize and accomplish with
the money and the time that you have at
seed can be important and customer
introductions feedback on roadmaps help
with positioning and strategic messaging
and PR so just kind of across the board
that's the way we like to help yeah yeah
and so you know if one of the things
that you're doing is working so closely
with the founders what kind of what
traits you're looking for in the
founders what really attracts you to the
companies that you invest in because
it's agencies of all about the people
yes it's a lot of it's about the people
and so you know high integrity high
intelligence people who have also shown
a certain amount of hustle and
scrappiness in figuring stuff out before
they raise money and then having kind of
an aggressive but doable plan
what they're going to do with the money
and make and within a reasonable period
of time so we usually suggest that your
seed round last you at least 18 months
if not 24 months or more than that you
know going a big a big mission and
vision that's quite ambitious that can
be backed up by here's where we want to
be and here's how we're going to get
there over time this is what we want to
get done the next 12 months in the next
18 months
you know relevant backgrounds if
possible or at least a personal
connection to the problem that the
person and the team is trying to solve
we'd love to see ideally some kind of a
techno tech Nicole angle or a technical
solution that's this kind of it and we
also talk sometimes when we meet with
the women in each class so I will just
say it I do think it can be harder for
women to raise money than men and so I
think kind of that kind of sucks and we
will fix it over time but for now the
thing we have to do is know what you're
up against being a woman entrepreneur
raising money and a largely male
industry of these seas and understanding
then kind of where you are and what you
need to work on because a lot of
pitching all the other thing I would say
is storytelling is really important yeah
and being a great storyteller is
important and if you are not a great
story or you can become one I have seen
so many people who started out not being
great storytellers become excellent ones
and it's just a matter of feedback and
practice especially at that early stage
where you're really selling a dream yes
so in Folsom yes so you know you
mentioned that it's potentially harder
for female entrepreneurs to be pitching
to two male investors how does somebody
pitch to somebody who is not necessarily
their target market well hopefully there
are plenty of I mean hopefully you can
pitch women and the more we can do to
get more of women into the venture
industry the more women you'll have to
pitch but you look it's a 95% male
industry right they're very my denying
it right yes to have many men in the
room and but I look if you look at
Pinterest or house or stitch fix I mean
the majority of the investors and those
companies are men so obviously there are
men in the industry who understand
problems that they may not personally
relate to right why don't we it goes to
show doesn't if you have an enterprise
startups and the people who are you
pitching to aren't your users in that
situation I right so exactly it is
possible it's just all about that story
so definitely and I the folks at YC
publish a lot of great things about like
tips and tricks for how to go about
doing it but I think for many of you if
you're going into a fundraising next you
know generally starting out with what is
the mission and vision of the company
how big is the market venture investors
are looking for large addressable
markets what is the problem that you're
trying to solve who's on your team and
how relevant is the team what is the
product that you that you've built if
you have built something or what are the
wireframes look like what kind of
traction or feedback have you gotten
from the market in terms of whether
people are going to like the product or
whether they do like the product and
what is the financial model and the
economic model look like and what are
you going to do with the money that's
pretty much how I think those are the
main elements of the story and just how
you tell the story and the personal
narrative that goes along with that and
I think is what investors are really
looking for yeah and I think a lot of it
just comes with confidence as well just
walking into that room with confidence
so how would you advise the women in the
audience to be able to internalize that
and project it in those meetings ah it
is exactly what you said QC which is you
all there are some great examples of
women founders out there who have raised
a lot of money are building quite
valuable companies so we we know what's
possible and I think especially with a
lot of the news that's come out in the
past week we hopefully have a better
window than ever more openness more
support than ever I think there is a
gathering army of not just women but
also men who realize that the deck has
been somewhat stacked against women in
the industry for since the beginning of
the industry and that it needs to change
and so those are all good things and
there's also just such an amazing
ecosystem of people who have raised
money who can who you can friendly pitch
your story to and get feedback and
iterate I mean nobody comes up with a
perfect pitch right away everybody
iterates on it
gets feedback and practices and it gets
better yeah and I think that's that's
one of the things that people don't
necessarily realize that you know
there's a lot of people that can help
you with the pitch that have been there
and seed stage investors are very much
focused on helping their companies get
to the next stage and will help with
those pitches yes we do like to do that
yeah so I'm going to go there all this
news that you just mentioned you know
what anyone know about the news yes
anyone that want to have some stuff
going on recently and you know as a
female VC what was your take on it what
what can we do I'm pretty pissed off I
think we have to use it you know you
can't just be mad right we have to be
constructive we have to use this an
opportunity to come up with new new ways
of doing things new solutions using it
as an opportunity that it both is like I
think a carrot and a stick right like
there's going to be there's not going to
be one answers gonna be multiple things
that we can hopefully do to be
constructive with what we've learned in
the past week and I don't think that
this is I don't think the story is over
and I think more sad stories will come
out over the coming weeks about behavior
that shouldn't happen in the industry
that's unprofessional that's
unacceptable that will piss us off even
more and so we have to you know all of
you hopefully you know this will give
you more motivation to be successful to
kick some major butt with your companies
to build modern inclusive cultures to
bring out like to hire a diverse team to
to nurture and develop a fantastic slate
of lots of women and people of color on
your management teams and in your ranks
that will become the next generation of
CEOs and then
[Applause]
[Music]
and also we need more women investors
you know so I you know something that I
had I had the fortune of having
breakfast this morning with a bunch of
general partners at a bunch of women
general partners at different firms and
we talked about what can we do to help
the associates of principles the women
and people of color other firms so that
we have more people becoming general
partners faster so there are more people
to call when we have a successful
company that's going to have choices
raising an A or B or C we a boy ventures
are going to try and steer those
companies to modern firms that have
women and people of color in the
investing positions and if you all have
only men at your firm and we and the
founders or their decision but our most
of our founders feel this way if they
have a choice they would rather work
with a modern firm like why should we
make money for [ __ ] you know like
yeah for sure and you know when if a VC
misses a deal that turns into a hot deal
because the founders have said no I'm
not going to work with you that's how
change can happen yes so I think you
know if you have a company that's
successful for entrepreneurs and friends
of yours who are have successful
companies or if you're a great operating
executive that has going to have lots of
opportunities to be recruited to be a VP
at different companies you're making a
choice kind of with your feet or with
your wallet by who you make successful
and so I hope that you will use your
leverage to steer people and steer
yourself to firms and teams that are
inclusive and diverse yeah for sure it's
it's going to take a concerted effort
but we can we can get there so you know
we've talked a bit there about choosing
these modern modern firms to work with
but how else how else does the founder
you know what would they be looking for
an investor how do they decide who they
should be working with they do think
being networked with other women and
other entrepreneurs you know there was a
bunch of articles about how the
information that came both from the
information that came out has been kind
of an open secret in Silicon Valley for
years and some people know about it and
some people didn't but you have to ask
right so you have to ask we investors do
references on entrepreneurs before we
invest entrepreneurs and executives who
are thinking about joining startups do
references on the folks that you are
considering joining and hopefully you'll
figure out are they people of integrity
do they have skeletons in their closet
what do I need to know that I'm getting
into how's the culture and I'm hoping
that we'll come up with some way I mean
I think the great thing is that women
and other people are starting to come
forward and name names and talk
specifically about people or firms
they've had bad experiences with and all
this stuff has just been I mean it's
happened to probably most women in this
room you just eat it you know it just it
just makes this little pit in your
stomach that causes you to doubt whether
you're welcome in technology whether
that firm really wants you to be there I
mean so there's so many microaggressions
and little cuts that people people do
because subconsciously they're trying to
make you feel uncomfortable or they
really just don't they don't have
confidence in you but you should all
have confidence in yourselves and I'm
hoping that more people will be
encouraged that that you'll be a hero or
a heroine by coming forward and being
brave because it's a hard thing to do
but you know factually and using data
and evidence showing what's happened and
that it's not okay there are many people
to have your back because it's not okay
yeah yeah we get that we we ask founders
to tell us if investors have behaved
badly because we have the power to be
able to do something to help you know we
can we can stop them coming to demo day
or we can we can you know there's
numerous things but it's so hard to get
women to tell us who they talk to who
they are talking about and it just
requires so much bravery but the more
that it happens yes the the less bravery
it will yeah I really appreciate I think
in the last batch that we talked to a
woman said something about a male VC who
had said some very inappropriate things
and you all found out his name and
disinvited him to demo dance I was in
section that thank you welcome
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so we have to really talk too much about
your portfolio and the kinds of
companies that you look at you know what
where whether your interests lie so
being as being we are generalists you
know there are some vertical specific
funds like the only invest in health
care or big data or robotics we're
generalist funds our goal is to
hopefully identify and work with the
most promising startups at stage days
that are technology oriented startups
every year whether they're enterprise or
consumer oriented and so we have I think
a really interesting mix of founders and
companies that we've gotten to back some
of them are consumer oriented like
Britain co-brand List which is a company
that's launching on July 11th that we're
super excited about and on both female
CEOs and founders and also security
company's infrastructure tech SEOs and
is an enterprise SAS company that we've
backed also founded by a fantastic woman
CEO so it's really I think hopefully we
can be helpful and hands-on and all the
things that I mentioned like
team-building and go to market
strategies and helping you get ready for
your Series A regardless of what type of
company you are do you think that
founders should consider you know how
should they consider these funds that
say that the ethical specific this is
the annual list approach I mean the fun
thing at seed is one of the reasons why
I also decided to move earlier from
being a Series A investor to a seed
investor a seed is collaborative
so it's Series A generally the way the
industry works is you're going to pick
one series a lead investor and that firm
is going to own twenty to thirty percent
of of your for your company going
forward and and hopefully your prior
seed investors will invest pro rata but
you can't you don't split your your
Series days usually between two
different series a firms at seed we
don't we always co-invest with other
people so we can partner with a data
oriented form or an enterprise focused
firm or consumer oriented firm and we do
that quite and also with with angels
individuals who
have special expertise and relationships
with a founder so it's cut it's more
like a village and it's a team approach
to trying to help the company because
it's the riskiest time so we feel like
having lots of good people around the
table to help the company and support
them is more fun for us and it's going
to help the company more yeah yeah it's
definitely different that series
anywhere you have one investor who's on
you board and they're the ones the
service is driving it but yes the seed
stage it just takes like you say a
village yeah yeah and I also think
hopefully our village tries to help
guide and advise the founders on who is
the best series a board member because
that is really a big decision it's
really hard to get divorced from your
series a board member
right you should treat it like a like a
married is America yeah it's a dating
process and that person that's going to
help you grow as a CEO and if you want
to be a CEO that lasts for the next ten
years running your company making sure
that you develop a relationship of trust
with your series a investor who's really
who could try and get rid of you or
could help you develop is a big deal and
that's one of the things that we work
with our founders on is trying to help
them find that right person mm-hmm so
we're running out of time but so you
know we have we have a roomful of women
here so many of them as we've seen a
founders what's the you know biggest
piece of advice you can you can give to
them to help them pitch to a seed
investor and be successful so as I
mentioned I do think that women have to
walk a finer line in today's environment
of mostly Mel B C's than guys do like as
you may have heard me I try and say this
whenever I have the opportunity like
what if my trigger phrases is he's such
a good guy
I can't stand that phrase like the
phrase good guy people say it all the
time and it doesn't really mean much
other than like high five we love that
bro let's go shoot some hoop yeah
exactly and I see this all the time you
know in meetings with these VCS where if
we have a company that's doing well and
we're thinking about who we're going to
call for our series day and it's mostly
men around the table and myself and we
or make a Google Doc of like who are
that you know who are the target
investors for the round and someone will
be like oh what about
Scott Jones and someone else would be
like I love that dude he's such a good
guy
and then someone else will say oh what
about Brian Smith it's like I love that
dude love that guy
put him on the list and it doesn't mean
anything
like he's going to be a great board
member and that we should get married to
him for 10 years but then if I bring up
a woman
what about Suzy Smith they'll say oh did
she invest in security like there's no
oh she's such a great girl or she's a
great woman like it's just us it's
infuriating yeah but that's kind of what
happened but the same thing happens to
entrepreneurs like if you pitch or a
group of guys pitch in the closed
session after you leave the VCS be like
I just love those guys and some of us
would be like you have such good guys
love those guys so fun to work with and
yours like her but it's not fair because
they don't fit they can't say that about
women like it's such a like what if I
say something that's offensive or like I
just love that woman what does that mean
like women dime-sized about women either
it's I know it's not fair so like we
should stop saying it but that's kind of
the world that we live in right so
advice we like to give women
entrepreneurs is you know be confident
but don't stretch if you are a little
too arrogant or you if you kind of puff
things up a little bit too much they
will they will ding you for being an
exaggerator so that's one thing but you
know don't be too shy or or under
confident because to be honest I think
guys can get away with being oh he's
just an introvert whereas women and
there was an article recently that
basically showed a quantity like
quantitative study that showed that
women and men get get different
judgments and they get different
questions depending on basically by
investors so it is not fair we just have
to know how the deck is stacked and work
around it so you know practice your
pitch do you come across as confident
but not overconfident and not spinning
because they will ding women for over
spinning know your numbers women are
overly dinged for not being quantitative
enough I have a friend who works at a
unicorn company who her father's a math
professor she was a math major she was
the CEO for a company doing 100 million
dollars in revenue and like in charge of
quantitative acquisition marking all
these things when she interviewed this
unicorn company first of all all of her
interviews with with men and every
single person asked her how do I get the
confidence that your quantitative enough
like there's just no way that men get
those kind of questions
no so just know your numbers it's not
you know so someone asks you what's the
CAC what's the LTV what are the margins
what's the revenue plan for next year
just know it just practice it and if
those the things that you don't know
about so you're not sure how to how to
calculate them these are the things that
you can ask for help from from so many
people around and and yeah you know
women really do have to know those
numbers back to front because they will
get pushed on them much more so that is
so important be good at follow-up give
you if someone else if people are asking
you questions or there's some follow-up
things take notes send any will the next
day and say here are the things that we
discuss a wonderful bond these points
like showing that you're super
conscientious and that you're on it well
actually there's like I think there are
some women who get put into this
category of like she's a killer like
that's kind of category that you want to
be in that's how men think about there's
like women and there's like women
killers and like oh my god she's an
animal like she just like was all over
her [ __ ] and she just knew her numbers
she followed up like she's an animal and
I mean to be honest VC firms that are
mostly male do you want it they want to
show the world that they are that they
get it that there's with it and they
also know that it's just women and
because they don't attract women
founders they are going to be leaving a
lot on the table and it's going to be
harder for their firm and for their
portfolio companies to attract women or
people of color if they don't walk the
talk in some way and so I think they are
more open for business than ever to back
a more diverse set of adverse that's
great for us right we can we can do this
you just need to know what you need to
do fantastic well thank you so much
today
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
you